[Music]
it's that time of the month again the
playstation plus games have officially
been announced for april 2022. all ps
plus subscribers can download the
following games from tuesday april 5th
by the way i'll be breaking down the
changes to ps plus in a video later in
the month because today it's all about
the games let's do this first up on both
ps4 and ps5 here's hud outlaws and
legends released only 10 months ago this
is best described as a stealth action
heist set in medieval times we are
effectively robin hood a team of four
outlaws attempt to break into a heavily
guarded outpost to steal gold all the
guards are ai controlled and won't
bother you too much and that's where the
game pivots because another team of four
outlaw players want that loot two the
match is broken into three stages
locating the key to get inside which is
found on a randomly generated minibus
stage two is opening the vault and
claiming the loot inside and finally
stage three is running all the way back
to safety sounds simple right well at
any point the other team of players can
attack your squad making the last 10
minutes of each game a complete
bloodbath there are a handful of classes
to choose from including a ranged archer
a tank-like brawler who can carry the
chest much quicker than anyone else a
mystical healer and a huntress who can
turn invisible briefly more classes have
been added since then including the
sellsword ida on release there simply
was not enough content to keep the
audience playing which is likely why ps
plus is here to try and resurrect the
game hood outlaws and legends scores
average out at 6.5 out of 10 so i guess
we officially call this an ok game over
to the ps4 now we have spongebob
squarepants battle for bikini bottom
rehydrated that's a long title this is
billed as a complete remake of the
beloved original from back in the ps2
days but realistically it's more of a
remaster as it certainly still feels
like a game stuck in 2003. as you can
see battle for bikini bottom is a
platformer which allows us to switch
between three playable characters
spongebob patrick and sandy you'll need
those characters to solve different
puzzles as they each have different
abilities to utilize the campaign will
take the average player between 8 and 10
hours to complete and if you're looking
for an easy platinum trophy you'll have
it done in about 15 hours in total in
terms of difficulty spongebob
squarepants battle for bikini bottom
rehydrated is aimed at kids but if you
like the show it's worth a nostalgia hit
too average scores tells this is a six
out of ten game three is slayed aspire
and let me promise you it's way better
than any video footage can show you this
game regularly gets nine out of ten
review scores slay the spire is a card
based roguelike let me explain we are
tasked with climbing up a spire we are
given a basic stack of cards and use
them in battles with random beasts and
monsters each victory gifts us a new
card which then shapes our deck for the
next battle over time you'll learn which
cards work well together it's all about
synergy and once you've perfected one
deck there's another three character
types to go through from straight up
damage builds to in-depth orb mechanics
which makes no sense unless you've
played the game let me put another way
if you enjoy gwent hearthstone and other
deck building games give this a try it
may not look impressive but it's crazy
addictive and game 4 is a reminder that
gta online is free to ps plus
subscribers who have a ps5 right now you
have until june 14th to add it to your
library to keep it forever if you
haven't ventured into los santos for a
few years going back is quite impressive
i've just returned to the game there is
a ton of things to do unless you're in a
lobby with human turds who dive bomb you
at every opportunity so much fun so
that's your bag for april 2022 let me
know your thoughts in the comments and
what you're playing this month i'm adam
you're awesome i'll see you next time
[Music]